皆さんは、星のピノのご存知でしょうか？
普通のピノを買うと
ごく稀に星形のピノが
すごい低い確率で
入っているらしいでございます
あの、今日僕が、したいのはですね
ちょっと、まさきにね
すごいハッピーなドッキリを
してあげようと思っておりまして
開けます...
全部星のピノ！
ウエエェェェ！
ハート型もあんの？
らしいスッヨ
星型のピノが
入っている出現率は
4.8%
二二箱分の一か
ハート型ピノは
3.2%
三三箱分の一
もう何でもいいんスよ
星ぃ
丸じゃなければいいんでしゅよ
まぁ、仮に星型のピノが三つ
入　ハ
っ　ー
て　ト
る　型
と　の
な　ピ
る　ノ
と　が
三
つ
七　三
千　億
百　八
七　千
十　二
六　百
分　六
の　十
一　五
の　万
確率でございます
七　三
千　億
百　八
七　千
十　二
六　百
分　六
の　十
一　五
の　万
確率が
目の前で起きると
失神で倒れても
不思議ではない状況です
まさきを
喜ばせようと
何より嬉しいと思うよ
本当
泣　　泣
く　　く
ん　　よ
吐血するよ本当
ええ、まあ
何気ない幸せを
我々が
彩ってあげましょう
準　合
備　わ
し　せ
な　て
い　六
と　つ
始　今
ま　回
ん　の
な　企
い　画
の　は
で
、
離　ま
し　ず
て　は
き　ピ
ま　ノ
す　を
では
ピノ購入....
帰宅中.....
う　店
ち　員
の　さ
冷　ん
凍　も
庫　う
に
、
こ　入
れ　ん
買　な
い　い
す　よ
ぎ　多
て　分
大　え
き　、
い　冷
っ　凍
し　庫
ょ
？
、
届　溶
け　け
る　る
わ　前
に
ピ
ノ
百　と
五　り
十　あ
一　え
個　ず
あ　こ
る　こ
の　に
で　ピ
ノ
が
集　と
め　り
た　あ
時　え
点　ず
で　六
つ
もう完成するので
早　溶
く　け
見　る
つ　前
け　に
ま　と
す　り
あ
え
ず
はい
よし、探そう
ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ス　や
ピ　ば
ー　い
ド　マ
だ　ジ
こ
れ
は
あーダメだわ
あ～↑？
はい
ハッ、ハッ、ハート
ハートx5
ア”！ア”！ア”！
今出たよ
うぉぉぉぉでたぁぁ！！
ア”ア”ァ”ァ”ァ”ァ”ァ”ァ”！！ハッ！ハッ！ハッ！
ア！ア！ア！ハッ！ハッ！ハッ！ハッ！
ヤ　本
バ　当
イ　に
ヤ　マ
バ　ジ
イ　マ
ほ　ジ
ら
、
本物よ？これ
ね
早く　保存　保存　保存　保存
あ　今
と　限
三　定
つ　が
出　三
せ　つ
ば　出
た
の
で
数　と
字　り
の　あ
ピ　え
ノ　ず
が　天
文
学
的
な
あげられます
んx1
んx2
んx3
んx4
んx5
んx6
んx7
んx8
ウェェェェェ！
ア！x4　ハッ！×5
四つ目出ました
保　す
存　ぐ
保
存
、
ヤバイ
ち　ち
ょ　ょ
っ　っ
と　と
ヤ　ヤ
バ　バ
イ　イ
星形ピノ発見！
残り十個中で一個でも
ミ　星
ッ　か
シ　ハ
ョ　ー
ン　ト
ク　が
リ　出
ア　れ
で　ば
す
、
本　な
当　か
せーの
やったx3
終わりx4
保存x4
で　は
や　い
め　、
た　と
ん　い
で　う
す　わ
け　け
ど　で
も　途
中
とりあえず六つ出て
ハ　星
ー　の
ト　ピ
が　ノ
一　が
つ　五
個
全部星行っちゃう？
狙いますか
ここまで来ると
もう全部星の方が
まだ全部開けてないので
と　残
り　り
あ　も
え　ち
ず　ょ
っ
と
開けてみて
もうここまで来るなら
全部星のピノの方が
思　い
う　い
ん　ん
で　じ
もう少し開けてみます
全部（ry
ウォォォ”ォ”ォ”ォ”
やったアァァ”ァ”ァ”ァ”ァ”‼
え、マジでマジで出た
ありました
星のピノ
モ　シ　モ　シ...
wwwwww
もしもし？
もう寝てた？
ん
寝てたよね
起　ご
こ　め
し　ん
て　ね
ま
さ
き
渡　ち
し　ょ
た　っ
い　と
物　ど
が　う
あ　し
っ　て
て　も
さ
、
イマ？
今　う
渡　ん
し　出
た　来
い　れ
な　ば
な　元
ん　か
か　ら
嫌　開
じ　い
ゃ　て
ん　る
と
や　ペ
っ　リ
て　ペ
欲　リ
し　ペ
い　リ
か　は
ら
、
はい、これで無事
ご　全
ざ　部
い　星
ま　の
す　ピ
ノ
で
このままケースに戻して
で、蓋押して
糊でくっ付けます
オケ
確率で言うと
九　一
千　億
九　千
百　三
四　百
分　三
の　十
一　七
の　万
確率で出現する
幻の
ご　全
ざ　部
い　星
ま　の
す　ピ
ノ
で
ヤバいよ本当に
で　そ
す　れ
か　ぐ
ら　ら
ね　い
の
白
俺の最高の後輩まさきに
行　プ
っ　レ
て　ゼ
来　ン
ま　ト
す　し
に
行って来ます
場　ま
所　さ
に　き
来　と
ま　の
し　待
た　ち
合
わ
せ
の
もうあそこに
待ってるんですけども
↑不審者やないかい↑
掛　一
か　万
っ　五
て　千
行きましょう
ごめんね突然呼び出して
ほんとごめんね
っ　こ
て　れ
意　か
味　ら
も　も
込　宜
め　し
て　く
プレゼントします
ちょっと開けてみろ
全部星ぃ？
絶対後で入れたじゃん
デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓
テゥー↑　テ↑レ↑レ↑レ↓レ↓
テ↓テ↓テ↓テ↑　テ↑テ↑テ↑テ↓テ↓
テ↓レ↓レ↓レ↑　テ↓テ↓テ↓　テ↓〜↑テ↓テ↑テ↓
テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓
テ！テッ！♬
まさきこれマジ本当
掛　マ
か　ジ
っ　一
て　万
る　五
か　千
ら
ね
、
満足して頂けたかい